pour en débattre au nous sommes avec
emilie marsh conseillère régionale à
france insoumise auvergne rhône-alpes
bonsoir emilie marsh à vos côtés kevin
bossuet professeur d'histoire en
seine-saint-denis bonsoir kevin bossuet
merci d'être avec nous alors c'est une
phrase un polémique donc de frédéric
vidal depuis dimanche soir je vous
propose tout d'abord de l'écouter avant
de vous faire réagir
je pense que l'islamo gauchisme gangrène
la société dans son ensemble et que
l'université n'est pas imperméable
l'université fait partie de la société
d'alors cabinet à bossuet on en a
souvent parlé puisque vous êtes de temps
en temps notre invité sur ces sujets
vous dénonciez souvent cet islam au
schisme qui règne dans les rangs de
l'éducation nationale il ya selon vous
une prise de conscience en tout cas ce
serait votre avis on imagine ce soir de
la part de frédéric vidal oui évidemment
de prise de conscience
enfin on s'est rendu compte que dans ce
pays il y avait un problème il n'y avait
pas à projets avec le christianisme il
n'y avait pas un problème avec le
judaïsme il y avait un problème avec
l'islam radical
cela fait des années en effet que la
france est gangréné par cette idéologie
est gangréné par ces gens qui détestent
la france qui déteste la république et
surtout qu'ils adaptent qui adoptent la
stratégie de l'entrisme c'est à dire que
le but c'est d'être présent partout
c'est d'être présent dans l'éducation
nationale c'est d'être présent dans les
universités c'est d'être présent dans
les associations dans les clubs de
football afin de répandre cette
idéologie et afin d'abattre la
république française et d'abattre la
france est évidemment que frédéric vidal
a raison de mettre en avant la montée de
l'islam au gauchisme au sein de
l'université
il ya des choses qui se passent dans nos
universités qui sont inacceptables moi
je me souviens qu'il y a deux ans à
l'université paris v et on avait
retrouvé des talent des tags qui
relevait du racisme anti blanc qui avec
des cales c'était mort aux blancs
français égale je me suis trop blanc
feuilletons à qui paul anti-france
vaincra c'est quelque chose qui n'est
évidemment pas accès pas acceptable et
même
au niveau des enseignements on voit bien
qu'il ya une frontière qui n'est pas
très nette entre l'enseignement d'un
côté et le militantisme de l'autre il ya
une percée dans le monde universitaire
de ce qu'on appelle les études
postcoloniales qui voudraient notamment
faire passer l'occident pour pour une
entité raciste pour une entité
suprématie ce n'est évidemment pas
acceptable
évidemment qu'il faut préserver la
liberté au niveau de la recherche
évidemment il faut permettre aux débats
au sein de l'université mais quand vous
avez une partie des enseignants qui est
terrorisée par une autre tout simplement
parce que l adapt elle n'adopte pas la
bonne idéologie il y à un véritable
problème donc lui il faut une enquête
il faut même aller plus loin une enquête
dans toutes les sphères de la société
pour vaincre l'islamisme comme on a
essayé de vaincre le nazisme il y à
quelques décennies donc à vendre est
faire réagir et mini marche on va
écouter aussi l un de vos tweets puisque
vous vous êtes exprimé sur les réseaux
sociaux aujourd'hui écouter à part
demandé la démission de frédéric vidal
et jean michel blanquer hier que c'est
faire la gauche
pas grand chose oui il y à un islam au
gauchisme qui en train de ravager notre
société tous ces gens qui refusent de
condamner l'islamisme sont des dangers
publics alors emilie marsh vous êtes
la gauche a en tout cas vous représenter
la gauche ce soit dans ce débat que
répondez vous à ces attaques
alors moi déjà si une gangrène dans
l'université actuellement ça s'appelle
la précarité étudiante à ce qu'on a
quand même 5 étudiant sur sept qui ceux
qui s'estiment en difficulté de santé
mentale on a des étudiants qui sont dans
une détresse on a des files d'attentes
au niveau des banques alimentaires et
pour moi mon avis la mini c'est
l'enseignement supérieur recherche
plutôt que d'aller chercher des
polémiques ou une chasse on se croirait
en plein maccarthysme ferait mieux de
s'occuper de haut niveau de ce qui est
en train de se passer dans une
université et de réouvrir les fac parce
que ce que demandent les étudiants et
les étudiantes en grande majorité
actuellement c'est pouvoir avoir des
cours avec un professeur est pas
forcément devant un écran
voilà moi je commence enfin en fait
c'est un débat voilà ça excite juste
quelques personnes alors qu'on n'est pas
en train de parler des sujets qui sont
en train de on n'est pas en train de
parler pendant ce temps là qu'on concret
c'est ces polémiques des entreprises qui
licencient à tour de bras de la deûle m2
de la précarité qui est en train de
s'installer et non non on crée on crée
des polémiques et moi je suis assez en
accord avec le communiqué de presse qui
a eu la conférence des présidents
universitaire quand même qu'on va pas
dire on est un organe de gauche en kaki
alerté par rapport à ça et aussi le
communiqué de presse du cnrs ou en plus
juste l'islamo gauchisme n'est pas un
concept scientifique et d'où une
ministre aussi va commander 6ème
vraiment qui est plus d'enquêtés de
travaux scientifiques en sciences
humaines et sociales
elle ferait bien d'abord d'augmenter le
budget parce que depuis plusieurs années
quand même il est vraiment à la baisse
justement on va l'écouter cette colère
des présidents d'université écouter
cette publié cette tribune pendant
qu'ils ont publié hier elle est
intitulée ils s'aiment au gauchisme
stopper la confusion et les polémiques
stériles
la cpu fait part de sa stupeur face à
une nouvelle polémique stérile sur le
sujet de l'islamo gauchisme à
l'université la cpu s'étonne de
l'instrumentalisation du cnrs la cpu
appelle à élever le débat
le débat politique n'est par principe
pas un débat scientifique
il ne doit pas pour autant conduire à
raconter n'importe quoi
d'où viendrait kevin bossuet ces
confusions auquel fait référence la
conférence des présidents d'université
donc en fait il ya aucune confie
confusion ce sont des gens qui sont des
idéologues ce sont des gens qui sont des
militants et qui n'accepte pas en effet
quand on entre dans les universités pour
voir ce qui s'y passe vraiment voyez
par exemple votre invité moi je pensais
que la gauche bête et méchante et est
finalement morte et je crois que
finalement avec votre invité nous avons
une survivante puisqu'elle a passé quand
même le début de son intervention à nous
parler des problèmes sociaux ce qui est
vrai en effet il ya un vrai problème
social chez les étudiants qui sont de
plus en plus précarisés avec cette crise
de la cofidis mais je ne vois pas le
sujet la vérité avec les militants de la
france insoumis ce n'est jamais le bon
moment pour évoquer les sujets liés
notamment à l'islamisme et c'est quelque
chose qui n'est évidemment pas
acceptable
il y a dans nos universités un véritable
problème avec l'islam aux gauchistes
qu'est ce que c'est que l'islam aux
gauchistes c'est tout simplement des
gens qui refusent de condamner l'islam
radical boire qui se soumettent à cet
islam radical vous avez même dans
certaines universités ce qu'on appelle
de la censure quand vous avez sylviane
agacinski
la compagne de données jospin qui va
faire une conférence sur la gpa
l'université bordeaux et finalement que
sa conférence est annulée parce que le
sujet des plaies à une partie des
universitaires c'est quelque chose qui
n'est pas acceptable c'est une forme de
censure donc à un moment il faut
peut-être prendre un peu conscience de
cela parce qu'il ya quand même quelques
semaines il ya un enseignant samuel
pâtit qui a été décapité
à quelques mètres de son collège pour
avoir défendu les valeurs de la
république au sein de l'institution
scolaire et quand j'entends certains
enseignants dans l'éducation nationale
mme certain professeur à l'université
nous dire que finalement ce n'est pas
très grave il faut passer à autre chose
on peut voir pire que samuel pâtit
l'auraient bien cherché
ce sont des discours qui sont
inacceptables la vérité c'est que la
france insoumis c'est dans
l'électoralisme parce que tôt sur
certaines parties du territoire en effet
son beurre électoral
elle le fait sur le séparatisme elle le
fait sur le communautarisme et quand les
caméras sont ouvertes évidemment ils se
disent profondément républicain et quand
les caméras sont éteintes final on se
rend compte qu'ils ont des discours qui
sont pas foncièrement républicain a donc
à un moment j'en ai marre de cet engrais
cette extrême gauche qui est en train de
tuer notre république un moment il faut
un sursaut et je félicite madame vidal
d'avoir eu ce sursaut est d'essayer de
voir ce qui se passe vraiment dans
certaines parties de nos universités
emilie marsh clairement kevin bossuet
vous interpelle en tout cas vous
vous personnellement mais votre parti
c'est une réalité qu'il décrit lui en
tout cas que vous n'y auriez à la france
insoumise
non on ne nie rien du tout mais c'est
pas en insultant
tout le monde est une population
d'islamo gauchistes qu'on va régler le
problème qui assure sur sur le
terrorisme ce qu'il faut ça c'est des
moyens est ce que c'est par exemple plus
de gens dans les renseignements me dans
dans le renseignement parce qu'au niveau
de la police au niveau des moyens
humains on en a de moins en moins mais
c'est pas en qualifiant stigmatisant en
envoyant toujours des termes et en
accusant et en accusant les autres en
fait on en fait je ne vous permets pas
je suis je défend la laïcité je suis je
suis la garde et que oui mais par contre
c'est bizarre parce qu'on on stigmatise
toujours une
mais par contre quand moi je vois la
région 1 le président de la région ainsi
que que la droite et quelques d'autres
composantes se faire bénir chaque année
par monseigneur barbarin en tant qu en
tant qu élu de la république
1 pour les voeux à fourvière ça
bizarrement ça choque personne non plus
donc en fait non moi moi honnêtement les
les opinions heureux enfin je ne permets
pas et ça m'énerve vraiment fait parce
qu'il ne me connaît pas et d'où ils
m'attaquent ou iggy d'autres non à la
france est soumise
nous défendons la laïcité la laïcité et
nous sommes profondément républicain
après honnêtement c'est vrai que non
j'ai tout le temps peur en peinture
certain sens voilà par pur plaisir par
pur racisme en plus un peu parce que ça
ça dérange ici mais vous pouvez tourner
la tête mais six mois en fait ce que ce
que ce que je retiens c'est que moi je
trouve ça quand même extrêmement grave
que ça fait plusieurs semaines qu'on a
des étudiants qui se suicident que mis
en avant ça peut-être vous dire que tu
la survivante de la gauche mais je peux
vous dire que
je suis peut-être pas la seule
survivante parce que ça choque beaucoup
de personnes que nous sommes le pays qui
est la sixième puissance économique au
monde et qu'on a des étudiants qui sont
en train de crever de crever la dalle
affaires ddd des heures d'attentes pour
avoir un paquet de pâtes et un paquet de
riz est la seule réponse qu'on a de la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
recherche
cette crème polémique sur l'islam au
gauchisme franchement honnêtement je
pense que vu les urgences qui a au
niveau dans l'université ferait mieux de
s'occuper à trouver 900 millions d'euros
pour réouvrir les facs comme demande
les étudiantes et les étudiants parce
que là en fait ils sont enfermés au seul
juste les étudiants c'est les seuls qui
sont très petits 23e confinement parce
qu'ils sont tous les jours en visio et
caen et quand arrive la fin des cours il
est 18h ya le couvre ce niveau c est ce
que vous vous admettre triés par hasard
que frédéric vidal court un peu sur les
sur les terres du rassemblement national
à un an de la présidentielle
ce genre de sortie c'est électoraliste
pour vous mais absolument pas frédéric
vidal est une républicaine comme jean
michel blanquer est un républicain et
quand ces deux personnes en effet met en
avant l' islamo-gauchiste ils le font
tout simplement pour servir la
république pour renforcer la république
c'est quand même incroyable qu'à partir
du moment où on attaque l'islamisme dans
notre pays on se fait traiter de raciste
on se fait traiter comme étant des gens
profondément d'extrême droite
j'entends votre intervenants qui nous
raconte qu'elle est laïque dans ce cas
là faut qu'elle change de parti parce
que quand je vois jean luc mélenchon
aller défiler dans cette espèce de
rassemblement de lutte contre
l'islamophobie à côté de gens qui sont
des islamistes
je vous prie de m'excuser mais ça
m'effraie un petit peu et vous voyez
votre intervenante ne sait pas répondre
à la question à chaque fois elle d'eric
soit sur les problèmes sociaux ou soit
elle nous met en avant la question de
monseigneur barbarin je ne sais même pas
qui est censé n'est même pas le sujet
voyez bien que votre interlocutrice est
en effet indisposé parce que tout
simplement on est en train de s'attaquer
de s'attaquer à une partie de son
électorat qui surf sur l'anti sioniste
qui n'est en fait que le
nez de l'antisémitisme alors je ne dis
pas que la france ont soumis c'est un
parti sport ans et c'est leur semble
déjà lancé des françaises qui habitent
sur un territoire un sais pas enfin en
et nan je vous ai je vous permets pas
juste de dire ça et en fait c'est de
convaincre par nos propres valeurs et de
faire ensemble et c'est pas en
stigmatisant les gens qu'on voit qu'on y
arrivera mais madame est un problème
sourit le fait madame
le problème c'est que vous le faites et
cécile mama l'on vous habite sur un
sujet et vous parlez en fait être
d'autres choses moi j'aimerais vous
poser une question est ce que vous
condamnez l'islamisme dans ce pays
oui ou non est ce que ça vous pose un
problème vis mes mom et mais moi je
condamne toute forme de rec et de
radicalité qui a dans n'importe quelle
des religions parce qu'en fait il n'y a
pas que le problème avec l'islam
donc nous avons aussi des radicaux au
niveau de l'église catholique
nous l'avons aussi dans dans d'autres
religions en fait est que je ne suis pas
pour en mettre plus une en avant que tu
as eu une autre adacore donc c'est comme
ça on a en france un problème avec
l'islam radical et madame
le problème c'est le cal a dit et que le
problème c'est le judaïsme raser
complètement ridicule elle me fait
penser à aurélien dachier qui nous
parlaient qui comparaît notamment le
burqini à des serre têtes ou qu'ils nous
disaient au moment où on allait
s'occuper de la polygamie dans notre
pays qu'il ne fallait pas le faire tout
simplement parce qu on rentrait dans le
lit des gens ceux d'histoire est tout
bonnement inacceptable vous avez un
problème avec la république un moment la
france c'est l'art et youtube mais elle
est cette maternité les berner fait
quelque chose de très important
donc quand je vous demande si vous
condamnez l'islamisme et que vous vous
défausser pour me parler des religions
c'est qu'il ya un problème madame donc à
un moment donné si ce n'est pas le fort
est le mot de la fin
madame est ce que vous condamnez la
participation de jean luc mélenchon à la
marche contre l'islamophobie aux côtés
d'associations en effet qu'il y avait
quand même des accointances islamistes
j'attends votre réponse et le mot de la
fin s'il vous plaît me les marges
oui mais moi comme je viens de répondre
mais ça ne va pas vous plaire mais je ne
suis pas là pour vous plaire moi je
condamne toute forme de radicalité
qu'elle soit de religion pas et que oui
faut il faut la combattre il faut la
combattre dans les lois républicaines
que ton avant pour faire vivre la
république et faire les faire vivre le
vivre ensemble
mais ce n'est pas en stigmatisant
toujours les uns et on le doit
évidemment évidemment tu les terroristes
il faut les combattre
évidemment que le terroriste il faut il
faut les combattre les islamistes puis
des terroristes donc en fait c'est vous
qui êtes dans les amalgames
c'est vous peut-être dans la
stigmatisation quel est le lien entre
les deux merci en tout cas le privé de
compacts tout temps le terrorisme vous
mettra pas d'accord emilie marsh kevin
bossuet ou merci à tous les deux d'avoir
été avec nous d'avoir accepté en tout
cas ce face-à-face merci à vous